scp-682 vs scp-1933  who would win a huge hyper-intelligent  lizard monster who can not only adapt to  almost any attacks but also give them  back or a fat drunk guy dressed as santa  with irish cream for blood though to be  fair this irish cream will also turn  your blood into irish cream and kill you  foundation researchers siphoned off 200  gallons and fed it to scp-682  682 apparently really enjoyed this  because it drank literally all of it  even becoming intoxicated and collapsing  onto the ground vocalizing loudly  researchers hoped this fluid was  wrecking havoc on 682's internals but  instead it vomited up huge quantities of  this anomalous irish cream turning the  walls of its cell into irish cream and  subsequently escaping to go on another  deadly rampage happy holidays i guess